a millionaire who has cash lying all
around his house decides to show off by
throwing some notes outside however when
he does so the notes quickly evaporate
as if an external Force has burnt them
shocked the man takes out an expensive
painting and places it half outside his
House's boundary and just like the notes
the outer half of the painting
evaporates to make matters more bizarre
if a human gets out of the house he or
she ages extremely fast and Fades to
ashes within minutes but it was not
always like this for the man and his
wife has just a few days back they moved
into this house the man is mad a painter
while his wife Kate works as a
translator the couple is currently
moving to their newly purchased home in
Upstate New York for a fresh start the
strange thing about this property is
that its price is extremely low as
compared to other houses and every year
it keeps dropping it's almost as if no
one wants to buy it when Kate sees the
eerie looking house she has second
thoughts about the move but Matt assures
her that they're going to do just fine
Matt hasn't watched enough movies Kate
is startled by a dead bird inside a
cupboard in the kitchen meanwhile on the
first floor matt comes across a strange
key-like object in a pile of junk Kate
pities the dead bird outside and wants
to give it a proper burial but after she
puts it on the ground she is startled by
Matt dumping old furniture from above
Kate then proceeds to bury the bird but
when she turns back she finds it missing
as if it somehow flew away later as Matt
is busy arranging the rooms he comes
across a strange hole in the wall
curious he peels off the old wallpaper
from around it and notices A peculiar
looking cavity Matt stares at it for a
while and realizes that the patterns
match the strange key he found earlier
he quickly fetches the key and places it
on the cavity lo and behold the wall is
revealed to be a secret door and it
leads to a large Hidden room taken aback
Matt calls his wife to check out the
Revelation and so the two start
exploring but as soon as they set foot
into the room the lights around the
house begin to flicker as a result they
hold off on their plan to explore and
instead call the power company the next
day an employee from the power company
arrives and Matt escorts him to the
basement which shockingly has thousands
and thousands of entangled wires the
site is so strange that even the
experienced electrician claims that he
has never seen anything like it he also
tells Matt that there's nothing that can
be done about the fluctuating
electricity as the wires are just too
complex on his way out the electrician
expresses his astonishment at someone
finally buying this property when Matt
presses him for more information the
Power Company employee reveals that the
previous owners of the house were
brutally killed inside the property
Mattis caught off guard by the
Revelation and out of curiosity he
researches about the previous owners on
the internet apparently the house is
labeled as the house of Blood by the
media and it belonged to a couple named
Paul and Madeline Shafer the couple were
murdered by a man whose identity is
famously known to the media as John Doe
of the House of blood currently the
murderer is locked up in a psychiatric
facility after working all day Matt
heads to the strange room and helps
himself to a bottle of drink he quickly
empties it and wishes is for another
just like any alcoholic suddenly the
lights go out and when they come back
again a bottle appears out of nowhere in
front of him it seems as if the room has
granted His Wish Matt is shocked and he
nervously picks up the bottle confirming
that it is very much real this is an
addict's worst nightmare the next
morning Kate wakes up to an empty house
she looks for her husband everywhere
before eventually locating him in the
dark room to her surprise it is now full
of eclectic items including the original
Mona Lisa painting Kate nervously asks
Matt where he got the stuff to which he
explains that the room can grant them
all their materialistic wishes she
naturally finds this hard to believe so
Matt encourages her to make a wish she
wishes for a million dollars and after
the lights flicker several bundles of
cash appear out of nowhere Kate is
astonished but she's also spooked she
finds the whole thing sketchy so she
proceeds to leave however Matt stops her
and convinces her to have some fun Kate
eventually agrees and the couple spend
their whole evening ordering champagne
money and making love ah the wish of any
married man soon Kate begins to wonder
how the whole thing works but Matt
believes that it doesn't matter as long
as they're getting everything they want
the scene then cuts to the next day the
couple now have all the things in the
world but Kate gets depressed when she
realizes that they are all materialistic
things which don't have any real value
to cheer her up Matt suggests they try
for a child it's then revealed that the
couple have had trouble conceiving a
child in the past and Kate has suffered
from two miscarriages previously the
suggestion angers Kate as the couple had
previously agreed to accept their fate
and never try for another child she
asserts that she can't put herself
through that pain again and storms out
of the room Matt regrets bringing it up
but he decides to let her be on her own
for a while and goes out for a drive
however when he returns home he learns
that Kate has used the room to create a
baby enraged he immediately confronts
her about the decision saying that they
don't know about its consequences after
getting into a small argument Matt tells
Kate to use the room to uncreate the
baby however Herman maternal instincts
kick in and she refuses left with no
choice Matt himself decides to finish
the task but when the baby starts crying
he feels sad and changes his mind in
this way the couple decides to adopt the
baby and raise it as their own over time
the baby begins to occupy most of Kate's
time causing her to slowly drift away
from her husband one day a board mat
decides to visit John Doe at the
psychiatric facility to learn more about
the room before leaving he grabs a bunch
of cash from the secret room and heads
to town at the facility it is revealed
that no one has visited John Doe for
over 45 years posing as a reporter Matt
asks John why he killed the Schaefers
but the murderer figures out that Matt
is lying and that he is the new owner of
the house of blood he doesn't speak much
and simply advises Matt and his wife to
abandon the house as soon as possible
for their own good however John knows
that Matt won't move out because he is
driven by greed on his way back home
Matt stops to refuel his car but when it
comes time to pay he learns that the
cash he brought from the magical room
has turned in into dust taken aback he
rushes home and throws a bunch of cash
outside the house to his disbelief the
money immediately turns into Ash he then
places a picture frame half outside the
boundary of the house and surprisingly
the outside half corrodes away eager to
find answers Matt tries to Break Down
The Walls of the room but only finds
endless networks of wires just then he
notices Kate taking the baby out for
some fresh air Matt knows that this will
end in tragedy but he decides not to
stop her surprisingly as soon as the
baby steps out of the boundary he ages
into a young child within seconds this
sends Kate into a State of Shock and she
screams for help after the couple bring
the boy back inside the home Kate bathes
him and finally gives him a name Shane
here it is revealed that if any object
is thrown out of The house's boundary it
will disappear immediately but if a
living organism Ventures outside they
will age at a rapid rate and eventually
disappear in the next scene Kate puts
the boy to sleep and confronts her
husband about the room Matt finally
comes clean and tells her about the
murder of the previous owners and John
Doe he also tells her how things
disappear when they exit the house
meaning that Shane has to be kept
confined for the rest of his life
hearing this Kate breaks down in tears
several days passed by and Kate starts
to homeschool Shane she also keeps him
from venturing outside telling him that
he is sick and that there are germs
outside however the boy quickly gets fed
up with staying indoors and begins to
take his frustrations out on his mother
if Bubble Boy can do it I can do it he
says nevertheless Kate loves him a lot
as if he is her own almost all of her
time is spent looking after Shane and
expectedly this begins to take a toll on
her marriage on the other hand Matt
develops an interest in shooting it
helps him forget about his depressing
reality meanwhile little Shane continues
to try and sneak outside as a result
Kate is forced to board up all the
windows and doors except for the front
door one day she gets into an argument
with Matt and the little Shane overhears
his father calling him a figment of
imagination later that night a curious
Shane Ventures into the secret room and
learns about its magical powers he then
spends the whole night Reese searching
the place the next day the couple finds
the boy inside the room to their
surprise he has transformed the place
into an outside space Kate is Amazed by
her son's intelligence but Mack gets
upset and drags the boy outside the room
and hides the key suddenly the phone
rings and Shane picks up the call it's
revealed that it's a call from John Doe
Matt quickly snatches the phone back
from Shane and warns Jon against ever
calling his house however the murderer
mentions that he heard Shane's voice and
asks who wished for the child Matt
admits that Kate created him and
inquires if there is any way to stop a
room-created object from turning to Ash
in reply Jon starts unraveling
everything he reveals that he too was a
child created by the magic room and for
an object to escape the house unscathed
the person who created it must die it
turns out Jon's parents wanted him to
live so they sacrificed themselves which
allowed Jon to become a part of the real
world this means if Kate dies Shane will
be able to live outside the house as
Matt listens to everything in disbelief
Kate over here is the conversation from
another phone devastated she leaves the
house and drives away in hopes of
crashing her car however she can't bring
herself to do it while Kate is away
Shane pesters his dad with questions
about the room annoyed Matt tells him
that he's not a real child and tries to
drag him outside but the boy breaks free
and runs back to his room Matt quickly
realizes his mistake and apologizes to
Shane for his bad behavior later when
Kate returns home she finds the two of
them sleeping next to each other Matt
follows her to the kitchen and
reconciles with her soon the two have
coitus and unbeknownst to them Shane
watches it all go down well that's
another way to grow up too fast the next
morning the creepy kid steals the keys
from Kate's pocket and Ventures outside
the house when the couple wake up they
learn that Shane stepped outside and
aged himself into a man however Shane
still has the mind of a child he is
furious with Kate for lying to him about
the germs and points a gun at them
however Matt manages to tackle him down
knocking Kate out in the process later
she wakes up with Matt by her side with
a sad face he informs her that during
their tussle Shane got shot and passed
away he also mentions that he took their
son's body outside after which it
immediately vanished distraught Kate
rushes outside to find her son but to no
avail following this we are shown the
real mad gaining Consciousness in an
empty house he looks for Kate but fails
to locate her he then notices the lights
outside the hidden room flickering
realizing that someone is using the room
Matt tries to enter But learns that it
is locked from inside therefore he tears
a large hole in the wall and gains
access into the room the room is still a
fantasy world created by The Psychotic
Shane Matt walks through the woods and
soon comes across an exact replica of
his house it turns out after knocking
Matt out Shane's shapeshifted into Matt
and took Kate to the cloned home there
he forces himself on a grieving cage but
fortunately she realizes that it is
Shane pretending to be her husband and
runs to another room shortly after the
real mad eventually arrives and Kate
comes out of hiding however the the
other mat also arrives and confuses her
as Kate is caught in a dilemma between
the two the real Matt calls her by her
childhood name this helps her identify
the Imposter who she promptly pushes
down the stairs the impact reverts Shane
to his true form meanwhile Matt and Kate
try to run but the room begins to
malfunction and the house turns into a
puzzle Shane eventually gains
Consciousness and catches up to the
couple he stabs Matt to death much to
Kate's horror she breaks into tears and
Shane tries to comfort her but just then
he notices the real couple outside
making their way to the exit of the room
it turns out the couple cloned
themselves to distract the psychopath
that's dark those clones surely had real
feelings Shane follows them to the real
world and lunges at Matt in anger but he
falls right into their trap Matt grasps
him and forces him out of the door and
Kate quickly locks it from inside Shane
quickly ages turning into a duplicate of
John Doe he cries and begs her to let
him back inside but she stands her
ground and in a matter of seconds Shane
dies turns into a pile of Ash with this
the couple finally gets rid of their
Tormentor a month passes by Matt and
Kate have left the home for good and are
living in a motel the movie ends as Kate
looks at a positive pregnancy test in
horror unsure if the child belongs to
Matt or Shane subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching